figure live bonjour bienvenue nous
sommes en direct ce vendredi matin pour
un nouveau point de situation sur ce
qu'il se passe en Ukraine pour suivre
cette guerre bien sûr en Ukraine puisque
cela fait aujourd'hui un an que les
forces russes ont attaqué leur voisin
pour parler de ce sujet bien sûr je suis
avec Alexis firjack bonjour Alexis
bonjour Vincent adjoint au pôle actu
avec vous on va retracer un an de guerre
en Ukraine via les cartes et via cet
article de l'invasion russe à la
bataille de backmouth un an de guerre en
Ukraine racontait en carte un formidable
travail réalisé les équipes du Figaro et
la partie infographies nous vous le
conseillons cet article et on va
retrouver du coup cette carte qui va
s'animer et on va vous montrer petit à
petit ce qui s'est passé de cette de
cette pendant cette guerre en Ukraine
Alexis est-ce qu'on peut d'abord faire
un point général alors un point général
peut-être rappeler que c'est
effectivement les les un an de
l'invasion russe qui avait commencé le
24 février enfin dans la nuit du 23 au
24 février 2022 mais qui a un passif et
d'une certaine manière la guerre ne
démarre pas à ce moment-là mais en 2014
puisqu'en 2014 il y a eu c'est des
révolution du Maidan pro européenne qui
avait conduit à la chute du président
ukrainien prorus Yannick
on se souvient qu'il y a eu un accord
qui avait été parapher par la France
l'Allemagne et la Russie mais malgré
tout malgré cet accord et bien il y a
une covid j'avais dû fuir Kiev et donc
ça avait conduit à l'annexion d'une part
de la Crimée la péninsule du Crimée
qu'on voit en bas au sud
l'annexion de la menace lucrè mais par
la Russie qui a organisé des des
référendums qui qui n'ont pas de de
valeur légale du point de vue du du
droit international
ça c'était la première partie on sait
qu'il y a pas eu de combat en Crimée
mais la Russie avait déployé ce qu'on a
appelé les petits hommes verts de
Poutine que c'était des des soldats sans
uniformes avec uniformes et sans insigne
et puis la deuxième partie ça a été le
nom basse la deuxième zone
rose rouge
et alors là pour le coup c'est devenu
vraiment un conflit armé
sert de moindre intensité que
aujourd'hui mais déjà extrêmement
puissant il y a eu 15000 morts enfin
c'est pas du tout anecdotique et ce qui
s'est passé c'est la Russie n'est pas
intervenue directement mais elle a
soutenu des rebelles prorus qui ont créé
deux entités séparatistes la République
de deniès qui est la République de
l'ougance qui sont en fait les deux au
blast ces régions administratives de
l'est de l'Ukraine qui forme une grande
région historique qui s'appelle le
donbas voilà et tout l'enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est ça et donc ils ont pris les armes
contre l'armée ukrainienne au début
d'ailleurs les les rebelles n'ont pas
tenu face à l'armée U l'armée russe
notamment l'artillerie russe est
intervenu les
Ukrainiens ont été battus et ça aboutit
aux accords de
ces coordonnées avec aussi la France
l'Allemagne et la Russie qui était un
accord imparfait qui n'a jamais été
respecté par aucune des deux parties
puisque les combats ont toujours
continué là-bas les combats de bien
moindre intensité qu'en 2014-2015 mais
ils ont continué avec des tirs d'Haïti
riz absolument tous les jours
et si vous voulez les deux républiques
séparatives il y a une sorte de de Ligne
Maginot ukrainienne qui s'est construite
le long de cette ligne de fronde de 2014
et donc le 24 février
il est intéressant de voir que les
Russes n'envahissent pas juste le don
basse mais ils envahissent tout le pays
avec trois fronts et je pense que c'est
trois fonds
qu'on va récapituler on va le voir
effectivement sur cette carte que vous
vous allez voir voilà on les voit en
fait alors déjà il faut aussi rappeler
quelque chose je salue d'ailleurs aynar
qui est dans les commentaires qui nous
rejoint vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr tout
au long de ce live à poser vos questions
nous on est là pour y répondre comme
d'habitude vous le savez il faut
rappeler aussi que avant la date du 23
dans la nuit du 23 24 février ça se
passe pendant un moment pendant
plusieurs mois la Russie va amasser des
troupes à la frontière ce qu'elle avait
déjà fait en 2021 mais là c'est encore
au-delà et en gros elle elle masse aux
frontières de l'Ukraine environ 200000
hommes pour des exercices l'attention
monte il y a des négociations avec avec
les États-Unis la Russie fait des
demandes d'en sécurité
assez classique sur le le nom
déploiement de d'armement à longue
portée
occidentaux assez frontières la question
de l'avancée de l'OTAN
le mot occidentaux qui arrivent en
Ukraine en fait depuis 2014 mais c'était
des armements assez légers enfin bref
toutes ces questions là
jusqu'au dernier moment
beaucoup de gens notamment en France ne
croient pas la l'hypothèse du invasion
russe parce que ça paraît militairement
irrationnel et on va voir que d'ailleurs
enfin l'avenir Poutine
l'opération initiale a échoué d'une
certaine manière ça veut pas dire que la
guerre est perdue mais en tout cas
l'opération initiale a échoué et
finalement les Nuggets les négociations
n'ont abouti à rien et peut-être que là
en introduction je peux dire un mot mais
ce qui est étonnant depuis un an ou deux
si vous laissez le progressivement
Vladimir Poutine dans ses discours c'est
des discours fleuves qui ont duré une
heure deux heures etc finalement il
parle de moins en moins
de questions sécurité d'armement de
traiter de bref toute cette gestion de
l'après guerre froide de l'après 1991
mais de plus en plus il parle d'histoire
longue et quand je parle d'histoire
longue il rem total à l'histoire de la
Russie depuis le depuis la rousse de
Kiev au 9e siècle était le premier état
slave il rappelle les frontières
je sais pas par exemple que
en 1648 767 après la guerre Russo
polonaise et bien la frontière russe
c'est installé le long du Nieppe et 1767
c'est la date à laquelle Kiev
devient russe ou redevient russe dans
l'imaginaire dans l'imaginaire russe
parce que avant il y avait eu la rose de
KEF enfin bref la nia Poutine de plus en
plus parle des races d'histoire de
racines historique et vous voyez bien
qu'on change on change de rationalité
c'est plus seulement des choses
sécuritaires militaires au début de
l'intervention truc très politique au
début de l'intervention il parlait de
libérer le peuple ukrainien maintenant
il parle de récupérer le territoire dû à
la Russie en fait mais c'est là où il
est extrêmement ambigu c'est que les
rares fois où la Russie a évoqué des
objectifs concret militaire
en général ça s'est arrêté au donbas
après alors il y a tous ces concepts de
des militarisation des nazifications etc
mais voilà c'est pas extrêmement concret
comme objectif mais en revanche quand il
était concret il parlait du nombas et ça
les plus encore depuis septembre
puisqu'on va voir mais la Russie a
annexé quatre Oblats
au sud-est de la de la Russie on le
verra dans on va commencer voilà le 24
février l'armée russe se déploie sur
trois fronts différents ils vont arriver
donc on l'a on le voit par le nord par
l'Est et aussi par le sud on peut
peut-être s'arrêter là d'ailleurs faire
un premier pas pour comprendre parce que
là ici voilà même avant avec les flèches
voilà là ça donne une bonne idée en gros
de la de la manœuvre Russe donc il y a
trois fonds il y a un front au nord un
front à l'est et un fond au sud on va
commencer par le front au nord qui est
le plus important déjà parce que c'est
celui qui mobilise le plus de troupes
que tes russes et parce qu'il a un
objectif qui est la capitale qui a fait
pour ça évidemment
c'est deux facto le plus important alors
les ordres de grandeur et là on va se
rendre compte qu'il y a un problème dès
le départ c'est que les Russes
envahissent l'Ukraine avec moins de 200
000 entre 250 000 et 200000 hommes c'est
absolument rien dans la mesure où
l'Ukraine c'est plus de 600 000
kilomètres carrés donc c'est plus grand
que la France
je sais pas mais quand les Allemands
sont arrivés en France en 1940 il y
avait un million et demi d'Allemands par
la Seconde Guerre mondiale en 1943 quand
l'Union soviétique
il y a eu la grande bataille du don qui
d'ailleurs avait lu en Ukraine et les
soviétique attaquent les Allemands par
l'est pour franchir le nièpre qui est le
qui est le fleuve qui skill qui le grand
fleuve en deux l'Ukraine mais qui coupe
en deux l'Ukraine numéro Sud il y avait
2 millions et demi de soviétiques bon
certes enfin s'il y avait un million et
demi d'allemand mais vous voyez les
ordres de grandeur ne sont pas là mais
malgré tous les Russes le font donc le
fond principal c'est au nord c'est Kef
et en fait ils vont descendre ils vont
passer par la Biélorussie au nord qui a
un allié de la Russie et ils vont
attaquer des deux côtés ils vont passer
des deux côtés du d'une Nièvre il y a
150 km entre la frontière et le russe et
Kiev
à l'ouest sur la rive droite on voit
c'est la centrale de Tchernobyl donc les
Russes prennent la centrale de
Tchernobyl descend etc et puis font la
même chose à l'aise sur la rive gauche
alors là il y a deux choses il y a un
moment dont vous souvenez peut-être que
l'attaque aéroportée de l'aéroport de
Gusto bel et ça ils font parler parce
que c'est le moment c'est en fait
finalement l'échec fondateur de la
Russie en Ukraine parce que c'était
comme en fait ils ont fait un truc très
classique dans l'histoire soviétique
c'est qu'ils ont décidé de créer une
tête de pont aérienne juste à 20 km de
Kiev vous aviez un aéroport qui
s'appelle l'aéroport autonome de
ghostman qui qui est au nord de kevlo
vous pouvez le voir sauf que là c'était
un peu après c'est à dire que les Russes
c'était déjà arrivé de la Biélorussie
jusqu'à la au départ c'était juste des
troupes aéroportés donc les fameuses VDV
peut-être 1000 hommes qui ont été contre
2000 hommes qui ont été larg
dont l'aéroport pour établir une tête de
pont avec l'idée
qu'ensuite il y aurait des avions de
transport et Yushin 72 qui pourrait
débarquer des hommes tenir cette tête de
pont commencer à attaquer Kef et puis
pendant ce temps-là les troubles venant
de ville en Russie
d'avancer jusqu'à gustomer et d'assurer
les logistique le problème ça c'était
sorti dans la presse américaine
visiblement les Ukrainiens étaient au
courant de de l'attaque européen à Ghost
femelle et ça s'est transformé en
désastre pour pour la Russie puisque il
y a d'excellentes troupes des lits
d'ukrainiennes qui ont immédiatement
attaquer la tête de pont à Ghost femelle
elle n'a tenu que quelques jours et pas
suffisamment longtemps pour attendre
l'arrivée des troubles russes qui
arrivent justement
les trous bruts sont finis par arriver
de Biélorussie et on le voit là elles
sont arrivées au nord-ouest de Kiev
et alors là elles ont commencé une
tentative d'encerclement de la ville et
là peut-être qu'on peut avoir une carte
plus générale de l'Ukraine revenir en
revenir en arrière on va remonter
effectivement pour voir parce que en
fait il n'attaque pas que encore en
arrière parce que là c'est des roues de
russe
voilà une attaque pas seulement par par
le nord par les deux rives du Nièvre ils
attaquent aussi par l'est en fait via
oui une ville qui s'appelle soumis qui
est d'ailleurs horizontalement à peu
près au même niveau que Kiev et donc là
c'était les trop breuse venez
directement de Russie et donc l'idée
c'était de prendre un sandwich Kiev des
deux côtés du Nieppe plus par l'Est et
en fait les Russes ont avancé très vite
au départ mais ils ont avancé très vite
même là on le voit pas sur la carte mais
pas par l'est à un moment
ils étaient à 20 30 km de Kiev oui
d'accord mais le problème c'est que les
Russes ont avancés très rapidement en
en contrôlant les routes mais sans
contrôler les villes et leur ligne ce
sont leurs lignes logistique ce sont
étendues de manière déraisonnable d'un
point de vue logistique c'est devenu
ingérable et surtout les Ukrainiens ont
commencé une technique de guérilla pour
attaquer les arrières des Russes qu'on
commençait à être absolument épuisés
d'autant que là on s'en rend pas compte
mais Kiev c'est plus de 4 millions
d'habitants le périmètre de la ville de
Kiev pour l'ancienclé c'est 100 à 150 km
oui c'est absolument considère donc il
fallait rien que pour encercler qui là
je parle pas de prendre Kef mais rien
que pour un cercle il fallait une armée
considérable dès lors que l'effet de
surprise de gustomer avait échoué les
Russes n'avaient pas les moyens de tenir
ce fond du Nord et donc ce qui devait
arriver arriva le point le point
culminant de cette offensive est arrivé
en réalité assez vite dès le début du
mois de mars et dès les derniers jours
du mois de mars les troupes russes sont
retirés du front à l'appeler le Frontier
le russe et même se sont retirés de
soumis la police
derrière qui précèdent pour essayer de
rendre le retrait russe de plus en plus
difficile mais là enfin avril c'est un
premier échec
pour pour la Russie alors encore une
fois quand je parle d'un échec ça veut
dire que la Russie a perdu la guerre oui
c'est que ça on le sait pas par rapport
à ce qu'il voulait faire
échoué et cette étape a échoué mais les
ordres de grandeur ça c'est pas ça je me
souviens on le disait dès les premiers
lives qu'on avait fait tous les deux les
ordres de grandeur n'étaient pas là pour
que ça réussisse pour que ça réussisse
effectivement alors je salue Joe cost
qui nous a rejoint qui nous a rejoint
Lucas Chabot qui nous a rejoint
l'histoire en détail qui dit la qualité
des cartes est impressionnante et bien
on est bien d'accord on remercie bien
sûr le service infographies de nous
avoir fait ses cartes et ce magnifique
article que vous pouvez retrouver bien
sûr sur le site du Figaro alors il y a
un autre parce que on a parlé du coup
parce que là on a parlé que du fond
d'une heure voilà le front du Nord le
front de lait il y en a deux autres il y
en a deux autres il y a celui du Sud on
va commencer par le sud ouh ça allait
aussi très vite euh
parce que alors on va remonter pour vous
pour vous montrer
les forces russes sont en progressé très
rapidement très rapidement voir on voit
d'ailleurs sur ces flèches en bas hop
vous voyez
ça ils sont très rapidement pris
beaucoup de zones dans le sud du pays
dans le sud d'Ukraine alors vraiment
c'est le front on va dire que dans cette
étape une c'est le seul endroit
enfin des seul endroit où les Russes on
peut dire ont marqué des points et ont
réussi ils ont fait preuve de qualité
tactique d'ailleurs qui était bien
meilleure
qu'au Nord
il y avait plusieurs enjeux
le tout part du Crimée donc déjà c'est
pas facile vous voyez le la clé ml se
rétrécit comme ça et au nord de la
Crimée il y a que deux ou trois routes
par lesquelles passer donc déjà les rues
sont réussis cette première manœuvre qui
consistait à quitter la Crimée pour
arriver on va dire sur la partie
continentale première étape là les rues
sont deux objectifs et on le voit très
bien avec les deux flèches le premier
objectif c'est de filer à l'est pour
contrôler les les bords de la mer d'Azov
la petite peut-être petite mère qui est
devenue aujourd'hui une mère de facto
intérieure pour la réussite évidemment
pas le cas légalement mais c'est le cas
dans les faits donc pour créer un
corridor terrestre qui permet de relier
la Crimée
au Dombas c'est donc au territoire russe
pourquoi parce que vous voyez que
l'acrymé en fait il n'y a pas de liaison
terrestre entre la Crimée et le reste de
la Russie alors oui il y a une sorte de
Détroit qu'elle détroit de Kirch qui
relie la mer Noire à la mer d'Azov alors
les rues savaient construit un pont le
le pont de cairege avec un pont routier
un pont ferroviaire mais malgré tout
c'était extrêmement problématique pour
les Russes
et donc c'était un des grands enjeux
c'était stratégique et c'est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le seul objectif stratégique
que la Russie a réussi à réaliser c'est
de créer ce corridor terrestre entre la
Crimée et le Donbass et donc là ils ont
avancé très très vite ils ont pris un
certain nombre de villes melithopoles
berdience qui a un port et puis ils ont
avancé vers Mario Paul on parlera
ensuite qui permet de faire la jonction
avec le don-base puisque Mario Paul est
dans le non base dans le blaze de Donia
et entre les deux donc ils ont pris il y
a deux oblast au nord de la Crimée à
l'est il y a d'abord le black de Carson
et le ballast de zapporigia
et donc si vous voulez
dès la fin du mois de mars en gros ils
avaient pas encore pris loin de là la
ville de Mario Paul mais en revanche ils
avaient réussi à consiste
constituer ce corridor dont je vous
parle vers l'Est mais il y avait un
deuxième objectif du front du Sud qui
est la flèche qui part vers l'Ouest
c'est d'aller vers au dessin vers au
dessin ou en tout cas alors là oui
l'objectif stratégique c'est très clair
c'était de contrôler les bords de la Mer
Noire
donc pour ça
la cible stratégique c'est le port de
dessin qui est la troisième ville du
crâne le premier port d'Ukraine et qui
dans l'imaginaire russe c'est une ville
chargée de d'histoire puisque c'est une
ville qui a été construite par Catherine
II à la toute fin du 18e siècle puisque
au 18e en gros la Russie donc avance
depuis l'est elle a elle contrôle déjà
son appelait la mallorizia autour de
Kiev mais tout le sud de l'Ukraine était
aux mains des Ottomans et donc
du 18e et du 19e surtout du 18e c'est
une les Russes ont fait refluer les
Ottomans vers le sud et donc il crée
dans ce village de pêcheurs de dessin
qui était une ancienne colonie grec de
l'Antiquité il crée une ville un port
qui est la ville de dessin et donc dans
l'imaginaire rue évidemment c'est très
important on va très vite voir que les
Russes ne parviendront jamais enfin ne
sont pas parvenus au dessin et rien
aujourd'hui ne permet de penser qu'ils
atteindront au dessin un jour un court
moyen puisqu'ils ont même perdu du
terrain
bref le problème c'est que pour aller au
dessin il y avait une première étape
absolument stratégique qui était le
franchissement du Nieppe
là je sais pas si on se rend compte
quand même sur la carte ici c'est le
nièpre c'est un fleuve qui dans ces
endroits les plus étroits fait 2 km de
large et qui grâce au réseau des
barrages hydrauliques créer de du temps
de l'Union soviétique il y a des
endroits c'est 20 à 30 km de large donc
c'est ce que les militaires appellent
une coupure humide c'est à dire que pour
franchir le Nièvre
à une armée entière c'est extrêmement
complexe donc il y a des points de
passage obligé ces points de passage
obligé ce sont les ponts et notamment
vous avez une grande ville à
l'embouchure d'une Nièvre qui s'appelle
Carson et les Russes ont réussi en
quelques jours à s'emparer de Kerson ils
ont réussi à éviter une grande bataille
une longue bataille urbaine qui ont été
à la fois coûteuse et qui aurait permis
aux
Ukrainiens par des manœuvres de freinage
notamment de détruire les plantes sur le
diep donc les Russes ont réussi à
s'emparer des ponts sur le Nieppe et à
créer une tête de pont sur la rive du
coup droite du Nieppe donc c'est à
l'ouest du Nièvre et là ils ont avancé
avancé avancé et ils ont bloqué à
mikolaief quel est la deuxième ville et
dernière ville qui est aussi un peu
importe qui est la dernière ville avant
au dessin
les rues sont tenté dans
circuits mais c'est 200-300 000
habitants les Russes n'ont pas réussi il
y a un petit fleuve le Méridional qui
est juste à l'ouest de Mikola if ils
n'ont pas réussi à l'atteindre et du
coup ils se sont retrouvés coincés avec
une tête de pont assez large 50 km de
profondeur environ 100 km au nord parce
qu'ils ont réussi à bien remonter le
long d'une Nièvre pas suffisamment pour
pour aller jusqu'à mais c'était pas dire
de bêtises mais il y avait quelque chose
comme 10000 15000
[Musique]
km².
mais le problème c'est qu'une tête de
pont
c'est bien qu'on attaque mais c'est
horriblement complexe à défendre c'est
ce qui s'est passé et le résultat en en
parlera tout à l'heure c'est que en
octobre
les Russes n'ont pas réussi à tenir
cette aide de pont et ont dû refluer la
tête de pont et abandonner la partie de
la région de Kerson situé de l'autre
côté du niAme alors là on peut parler
tout à l'heure de du mois de mars alors
on a mon amour
on parlait tout à l'heure voilà de l'Est
vous voyez on disait 20 km à l'est vous
voyez c'est ça qui arrive ici ils
étaient juste à côté ils ont commencé à
vouloir
à vouloir encercler par bout de chat
justement mais c'était un enfer
logistique et il aurait fallu des
troupes que la que la Russie n'avait pas
voilà ils ont retrouvé très proches mais
finalement ils ont perdu et voilà et
l'autre point du Sud vous vous rappelez
donc pour faire un contenu là on est le
front du Sud avec
on le disait les Russes qui ont encerclé
la ville de Marie-Paule qui ont réussi à
créer un lien territorial entre le
Dombas et la Crimée grâce à cela mais
qui ont mis du temps avant de réduire
énormément de temps
à partir du moment où c'était encerclé
ils ont mis un mois et demi et la ville
de Mario Paul a été prise elle a à la
mi-mai si je le dis pas de bêtises j'ai
plus exactement les dates en tête mais
je crois que c'est la la mi-mai et
notamment les
ukrainiens et notamment le bataillon
Asos qui a un bateau bataillon
volontaire très nationaliste
ont résisté dans l'usine métallurgique
des OVS
qui restent
en guérisé on voit que d'ailleurs c'est
une zone c'est immense c'est absolument
immense c'est la taille d'une ville et
surtout il y a des il y a des
souterrains extrêmement profonds pour
vous dire en fait Mario Paul le Donbass
dans son ensemble
historiquement la zone la plus la plus
riche de l'Ukraine une zone industrielle
minière et notamment c'est là qu'on y
travaillait l'acier et ça remonte à loin
ça remonte au début du 20e siècle
et donc Mario Paul c'était à la fois le
port sur la mer d'Azov qui permettait
d'expédier
tous les produits fabriqués dans le
don-basse et en même temps c'était là
qu'il y avait une des plus grandes
séries d'une anci soviétique donc
l'usine metallorgique des obstacles et
donc là les Russes sont mis ont mis un
temps fou et ils ont notamment envoyé
parce que les Russes depuis le début
essaye il n'y arrive pas mais ils
essayent d'économiser leur troubles
régulières et donc pour toutes les
batailles urbaines qui sont extrêmement
en homme ils essaient d'utiliser
plutôt des troupes on va dire
irrégulières et donc là de même que les
Ukrainiens c'était le bataillon à
Herstal de Azov pardon
les Russes eux avaient envoyé les
bataillons tchétchen de cadirov qui
avait une certaine expérience de la
guerre en Syrie du combat urbain
et qui était plus plus mobile que que
l'armée régulière russe donc finalement
les Russes ont réussi à s'emparer de
Mario Paul et donc ce premier objectif
stratégique
donner lieu à ça à cette carte à cette
carte alors là il manque quand même une
chose dont on a pas parlé c'est le fond
de l'est effectivement voilà donc si on
peut revenir en arrière et là on
comprendra enfin qu'on va arriver là on
va revenir en remontant la carte vous
allez tout revoir qui revient en arrière
voilà oui juste après le nickel et en
fait là on voit si vous voulez y aller
dans l'Est il y a il y a une grande
flèche
qui part vers le nord
c'est ça et en fait c'est le on voit
bien la manœuvre Russe là encore elle a
raté mais on voit la manœuvre Russe qui
a consisté en fait tout à l'heure je
vous disais que les lignes de front 2014
dans le non-bass elles étaient
complètement fortifiées c'est une sorte
de l'imagino avec des des réseaux de de
trancher et mais pas une tranchée
c'était des kilomètres de de tranchées
et donc les Russes de manière assez
logique pour le coup d'un point de vue
militaire n'ont pas attaqué deux fronts
cette laine Maginot et ils ont entrepris
une manœuvre de tenaille à la fois par
le sud c'est le fond du Sud dont on
parlait et par le nord c'est la flèche
la longue flèche rouge là non on
[Musique]
important mais en revanche ils ont gardé
leur territoire au sud de la ville de
kerkiff dans la région de kerkif pour
vous voyez créer cette espèce d'avancer
de balcon au dessus de du Dombas l'idée
c'était de fondre comme ça enfin
du coup ça crée un champ de bataille qui
avait quand même je peux pas dire de
bêtises mais c'est un carré de 300 km
par 300 km ce qui était une vaste
manœuvre opérative et on a vu que les
Russes avaient réellement une capacité
de manœuvre qui était qui était
extrêmement faible donc cette manœuvre
par le nord
a échoué
notamment il y avait un centre centre de
cette de cette manœuvre qui était la
ville d'isium mais ensuite les Russes
n'ont pas réussi à descendre pour
attaquer les deux grandes villes
ukrainiennes de cramator c'est la
violence que dans le Donati alors une
fois qu'ils ont ils ont retrouvé bloqués
comme cela et là on est arrivé là voilà
là on comprend où on ne
et juste un point c'est ce qui est
frappant c'est que la carte qui est là
alors à deux exceptions notables près
ressemblent quand même pas mal celle
qu'on a aujourd'hui et donc là on
réalise qu'en fait la carte a peut
changer
depuis le mois de mai juin mais depuis
mes jurés effectivement il y a eu tout
de même à l'automne les deux grandes les
deux grands
ukrainiennes alors on va y retourner
donc là qui a fait Mario Paul
pour vous parler tout à l'heure avec
l'usine Mr
on va retrouver du coup cette carte
comme vous montrer et donc là c'est les
deux grandes offensives déjà on a cette
contre-offensive qui est dans le
nord-est
autour de cartes vous le disiez tout à
l'heure alors déjà ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est ce balcon cette avancée
russe au dessus du Dombas avait un
intérêt pour les Russes
c'était de mener à bien leur manœuvre de
tenaille pour mais sauf que la ligne de
front c'était arrêté je l'ai les Russes
n'avaient plus de moyens d'annoncer il y
avait atteint leur point culminant et ce
qui était un avantage dans l'offensive
devient
un défaut quand ils sont sur la
défensive parce que ça étire la ligne de
front
et ça met en danger leur flan et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé
c'est que du coup les Ukrainiens ont
commencé
à grignoter cette extrémité du front
russe
pas par l'ouest dans la région de de
carquif alors même que les combats les
plus violents lieu au cœur du non-basse
plus à l'est et donc à cet endroit là
sur les flancs les Russes n'avaient pas
beaucoup d'hommes ils avaient mis des
des volontaires entre guillemets de
des républiques séparatiste de Denis et
Lougansk
et ça allait très vite côté côté
ukrainien ils ont récupéré assez
rapidement ils ont récupéré vous voyez
entre un peu plus de 1000 km². alors
avec parce que là on a l'impression
d'une attaque foudroyante
ukrainienne
faut quand même un tout petit peu nuancé
en réalité les Russes
se sont retirés dès qu'ils ont vu le
rapport de force il y avait il y avait
un rapport de force à ce moment-là dans
la dans la contre-offensive de car kiff
donc à l'automne dans mon souvenir il y
avait un rapport de force de 6 ou 7
contre 1 en faveur des Ukrainiens les
Russes se sont dit ouh là là on se
retire on se replie sans trop de casse
c'est pas évident mais ils ont à peu
près limité à la casse et ils se sont
ils ont essayé de construire deux
nouvelles
lignes de front le long de deux rivières
qui s'appelle le skill lazy rebette et
on en parlera aujourd'hui l'un des
objectifs pour les Russes c'est de
vraiment dépasser pas de les dépasser de
d'atteindre complètement le skill parce
qu'en fait alors si vous voulez le vous
voyez le le croissant que forme la
peut-être que je veux prendre la souris
une seconde tiens
en fait les fleuves les rivières c'est
vraiment très très important pour
comprendre la
en fait il y a une rivière qui s'appelle
la denisque un affluent du don et en
fait qui passe par là qui fait une
boucle
top
qui revient comme ça
et en gros qui fait comme ça voilà et
donc là
tout le long du Nord là comme ça les
Russes ont eu le plus grand mal à son
chien la rivière mais en revanche ils
ont pas réussi à aller jusqu'au bout de
la rivière qui aurait pu protéger leur
flan mais la rivière elle est trop à
l'ouest et donc la manœuvre Russe de
développement dont on parlait tout à
l'heure ils ont pas réussi à aller
jusqu'au bout et donc c'est pour ça que
leur flancs n'ont pas tenu mais en
revanche il y a deux affluents qui sont
vraiment à la verticale de cette rivière
de nièce il y a le skill qui est comme
ça
et quelques kilomètres plus loin il y a
la zéabeth
et en fait les Russes au nord ont réussi
à freiner les Ukrainiens au niveau de le
skill et au sud ils ont réussi à les
freiner au niveau de l'azerbette
d'accord en gros c'est ça et maintenant
tout le l'enjeu pour les Russes c'est de
fortifier
cette défense mais probablement pas à
court terme d'aller plus loin parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens ils n'ont
pas forcément les moyens donc ça c'était
pour le front de
du Nord mais il y a aussi du coup pardon
on le laisse ensuite ils ont été obligés
les Russes ont été comme cette manœuvre
dans le cerclement n'a pas fonctionné
ils ont été obligé d'avancer par l'Est
et ce qui était beaucoup plus difficile
parce qu'ils se sont attaqués les
imaginons et là c'était les grandes
batailles de crfe de netsk et de
l'édition les deux villes il y a
justement la rivière de Nieppe entre les
deux dont on parlait
des visites un peu plus de 5000
habitants qui ont été prises dans les
premiers jours de juillet et ensuite
c'était la grande bataille de backmouth
qui est toujours en cours parce que ça
fait 6 mois que les Russes l'ont lancé
et ils ont toujours pas pris la ville
[Musique]
mais les Ukrainiens parviennent à
établir eux-mêmes une tête de pont
au-delà de les news et là il y a une
longue bataille avec peu d'avancées et
là les Russes ont un choix stratégique à
faire ils ont 30 000 hommes environ de
l'autre côté du Nieppe soit c'est une
longue bataille d'usure et d'être ici
mais ça va être extrêmement coûteux de
résister aux attaques ukrainiennes
surtout que les Ukrainiens grâce aux
armes occidentales et notamment aux
canons high mars les Ukrainiens ont
réussi à faire sauter les trois ponts
sur le Nièvre les deux de Carson et
celui de Novak et donc du coup la
logistique russe est un enfer pour faire
passer pour ravitailler ces 30000 hommes
c'est horrible et donc les russiennes
tiennent tiennent et au bout d'un moment
il y a un nouveau commandant
en fait il faut limiter les dégâts il
faut limiter les débats de les dégâts ça
n'a pas d'intérêt militaire dans la
mesure où cette tête de pont elle ne
sert que à aller plus vers l'ouest mais
si mais là les Russes n'ont pas les
moyens d'aller plus à l'ouest et donc là
il décide les Russes décident de se
retirer de l'autre côté du Nieppe alors
militairement ça fait sens politiquement
c'est un camouflet terrible pour gagner
en Poutine parce que déjà ça veut dire
que le blast de Carson il ne le contrôle
plus dans son intégralité
alors même que un homme en plus il a
fait des référendums pour l'annexe donc
officiellement c'est la Russie en droit
russe et surtout les Russes perdent la
ville de Carson qui était la seule
capitale régionale que les Russes
avaient contrôlé depuis le 24 février
alors c'est pas la plus grande ville la
plus grande ville c'est Marie-Paule mais
ça avait le statut de Capital régional
donc c'est un vrai camouflé politique
pour pour là aussi de ce qui est
important alors ça c'est la carte qu'on
avait on va dire à l'automne et qui n'a
pour le coup alors plus bouger c'est à
dire que voir les différences là pour le
coup
grande sur une carte
a aussi
petite échelle c'est quasiment
impossible faut vraiment avoir des très
bons yeux il y a des différences mais
qui sont de l'ordre de quelques
kilomètres dans l'est de l'Ukraine dans
le non-basse puisque maintenant c'est
ici que ça se passe c'est vraiment dans
le don basque que ça se passe c'est là
où les combats les plus violents et il
faudrait pas se dire que parce que la
carte n'évolue plus la guerre est moins
intense qu'au début
la réalité c'est qu'elle est plus
intense mais elle est plus quasiment
plus intense que qu'au départ mais plus
concentré ne serait-ce que parce que les
forces sont présents sont en reparlera
tout à l'heure mais elles ont augmenté
les Russes au début c'était 200 000
depuis la la mobilisation partielle
il y a 300 000 soldats supplémentaires
qui sont arrivés sur le front et qui
vont arriver sur le front c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont tous déjà engagés mais les
les ordres de grandeur bah sont il y a
une forme d'escalade de conventionnelle
et pareil du côté ukrainien avec des
vagues de des vagues de mobilisation
alors on va prendre alors je salue qui
nous auront qui nous a rejoint
Jean-Michel Alès Alex qui nous regarde
depuis le Québec juste pour rappeler ce
qui s'est passé moi je me rappelle on a
fait un direct il y a un peu plus d'un
mois et la ligne de France se situait à
solédar là aujourd'hui elle est à
backmouth on voit bien que ça avance en
fait la ligne de front était déjà nous
laisse de backmouth mais toujours pareil
les rues se sont dit on va pas attaquer
frontalement frontalement
c'est une ville dans l'Est il y a des
très grands immeubles donc c'est bien
pour voilà donc les rues se sont dit on
va passer au nord et pas le sud manœuvre
dans cerclement extrêmement classique et
donc le premier verrou à faire sauter
pour les Russes c'était Solena et donc
le si vous voulez on peut on peut dire
qu'il y a une forme de contre-offensive
russe qui a commencé il y a un peu plus
d'un mois maintenant je dis offensive
avec des guillemets on va dire c'est
plutôt qu'ils ont repris
l'initiative sur le terrain alors que
par avance c'était les Ukrainiens qu'il
avait depuis l'automne et qui avancé
mais en réalité on peut pas parler d'une
grande offensive au sens où il n'y a pas
de de grandes manœuvres c'est une guerre
d'usure et une guerre qui se fait km par
kilomètre pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée le le depuis janvier depuis le
1er janvier 202 par exemple les Russes
là où ils ont le plus avancé c'est dans
cette région là ils ont avancé de 10 km
c'est le maximum et en revanche sur
toute la ligne de fond quasiment à
différents endroits ils ont gagné t un
kilomètre 2 km 3 km mais ça peut pas se
voir sur la carte
qu'on regardait tout à l'heure mais donc
là c'est la grande bataille de bakoun
donc ils attaquent peu frontalement ils
ont attaqué par soleda et en fait c'est
une histoire de route en fait il n'y a
deux grandes routes la M03 qui est au
nord qui va vers la grande ville de
flaviance et il y a une eau de route la
T05 04 qui passe par event evanski et en
fait les Russes ça y est des amis
contrôlent la M03 la route du sud il a
contrôle pas
physiquement mais en revanche elle est
sous le feu russe et puis la dernière
petite route que les
Ukrainiens peuvent emprunter mais là
encore sous le Fleurus c'est un peu
moins que l'autre mais mais malgré tout
il y a le Fleurus c'est là c'est la
petite route qui passe par komov et qui
ensuite passe vers l'autre ville à
l'ouest de backgroute qui s'appelle
châshifiar et donc là les Russes
je vais même pas dire qu'il le met par
kilomètre c'est enfin centaines de
mètres par centaines de mètres avance
très très lentement
pour réaliser une tenue cette ton
cerclement aujourd'hui il y a pas
encerclement
réel enfin physique on peut parler d'une
forme d'un cerclement tactique au sens
où les d'une certaine manière par leur
feu les Russes contrôlent les
principales voies d'accès à backmouth
mais les les Ukrainiens ne sont pas
encore encerclé il y a encore
probablement quelques milliers de
soldats à
backmouth même et après bon il est quand
même possible que les Russes dans les
semaines à venir
prennent pas forcément prennent
background parce que si les Ukrainiens
décident de rester avec mouth et de
tenir le siège
un siège ça peut tenir des semaines des
semaines pendant des mois mais en
revanche si les Ukrainiens décident de
se replier pour pas perdre d'homme
et après les Ukrainiens pourraient
constituer une nouvelle ligne de front à
châssis FIA d'autant que on le voit pas
sur la carte mais il y a une sorte de
canal
qu'à l'ouest de backmouth à la à peu
près la verticale et qui aide aussi et
si vous voulez il faut se rendre compte
de la de la réduction d'échelle
géographiques des combats on parlait il
y a un an d'une guerre dans toute
l'Ukraine on parlait de de Kiev de
quartier de tcherny de surprise
avec des mouvements qu'elle allait très
vite aujourd'hui on parle d'un petit
point sur cette carte évidemment c'est
de 10 km je vais le résumer très
brièvement les Russes au début veulent
prendre caisse ils y arrivent pas
ils veulent prendre de manière générale
les plus grandes Kiev les plus grandes
villes de l'Ukraine n'y arrive pas du
coup nouvel objectif stratégie nouvelle
objectif militaire à la fin mars ah on
se réduit au dommage là l'objectif c'est
de faire une grande tenaille pour
prendre les deux grandes villes de
crémator et cela violence
ça marche pas alors du coup ils
attaquent de front et alors ils se
disent on va prendre une ville
qui est à l'aise de créateur c'est sa
violence qui permettra ensuite ces
backmouth et il y a quelques semaines on
parlait même pas de makmouth c'était
la la ville au nord de background de
bêtises non 1500 habitants
soleda qui permettrait de prendre
makhmoud donc il y a une sorte de
réduction de l'échelle des des combats
qu'il faut vraiment avoir en tête mais
nuancée par le fait qu'il y a
l'intensité des combats n'a pas elle
diminué qu'au contraire les forces en
présence ont tendance à augmenter et
qu'on est vraiment d'une guerre de haute
intensité comme on n'avait pas vu
depuis très longtemps alors on a pas mal
de questions
qu'à des eaux qui nous dit la tactique
russe est simple et primitive il envoie
ils envoyaient des milliers de chair à
canon et grignote les territoires
Ukrainiens petit à petit mais il gagne
effectivement il progresse ce qu'on
disait petit à petit sur le terrain
alors
[Musique]
c'est la fin de la partie qu'on pourra
dire
qui a gagné
ce qui est frappant aujourd'hui
et qui du coup change un peu par rapport
à ce qu'on disait à la à l'automne
on observait une vraie capacité de
manœuvre ukrainienne et où on imaginait
très sérieusement
une défadreus un effondrement du front
russe
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est que les
Ukrainiens
n'ont pas réellement aussi à reprendre
la manoeuvre depuis le point culminant
de leurs deux contre-offensives dont il
faut nuancer l'ampleur par le fait que
les Russes se sont repliés dans les dans
les deux cas et ensuite on s'est attendu
vous savez à cette fameuse
contre nouvelle offensive russe dont on
parle depuis des semaines et des
semaines et en revanche en réalité on ne
la voit pas venir cette
et la fenêtre de tir se rétrécit parce
que on peut faire une offensive l'hiver
parce que les seuls sont gelés parce que
les seuls sont gelés donc les chars
peuvent passer on peut faire une
offensive d'été même à la fin du
printemps en revanche entre les deux
saisons il y a un mois un mois et demi
pendant lesquels on peut pas faire de
grandes manœuvres parce que c'est les
seuls sont boueux et donc la capacité de
manœuvre et affaiblie et donc là la
fenêtre de tir pour les Russes
[Musique]
est vraiment faible et donc il y a
beaucoup d'experts qui ont des doutes
sur le fait que les les Russes à ce
stade vont vraiment lancer une grande
offensive il est plus probable qu'il
continue
cette technique de grignotage
qui en fait une guerre d'usure si la
ligne de front se concentre en un point
de la carte
et c'est à celui qui tiendra le plus
longtemps donc c'est combien vous perdez
de force à la fois des hommes et du
matériel chaque jour quel est votre
stock combien vous pouvez en
reconstruire ça fait une équation tout
simple et après c'est qui tient le plus
longtemps possible je dis équation toute
simple la seule chose c'est que
de nombreuses inconnus cette équation
personne n'allait donner de ça c'est à
dire que enfin en tout cas on source
ouverte et facilement enfin moi je ne
les ai pas
c'est-à-dire quels sont les stocks
russes et ukrainiens en matériel en
munitions
quels sont les capacités en homme il y a
des normes inconnues et est-ce que
Vladimir Poutine va finir par lancer une
nouvelle vague de mobilisation les
Ukrainiens depuis des semaines
maintenant craignent une annonce en ce
sens ils ont même cité des chiffres 500
000 hommes et si la Russie envisage une
nouvelle offensive en réalité elle aura
besoin
de ces hommes là de ces ne serait-ce
parce que l'offensive va va créer de la
pression parmi les forces actuellement
donc le seul moyen quand vous lancez une
offensive faut mobiliser parce que sinon
vous terminez votre offensive et là vous
êtes à sec entre guillemets et il faut
aussi rappeler que le
que la mobilier immobilisation générale
par contre en Ukraine qui n'a pas
forcément qui n'a plus elle la capacité
de remobiliser et énormément d'hommes
elle elle en a encore simplement si on
regarde les les deux bouts on va dire il
y a un pays de 145 millions d'habitants
d'un côté il y a un pays
de de moins de 40 millions d'habitants
de l'autre mais en revanche si vous
voulez je pense que les Ukrainiens
aujourd'hui ont quand même plus envie
d'aller se battre
que les Russes donc l'acceptation
politique et sociale de la mobilisation
est plus forte en Ukraine
on a Joe cost qui nous dit les rues
s'appellent cela une opération spéciale
c'est la lumière Poutine qui emploie ce
terme depuis le début car ils ne sont
pas nombreux ils nous disent allez à
aller sur le terrain tout est relative
bien sûr si plus d'hommes rentrent dans
la danse Poutine par leur a-t-il de
guerre ou toujours pas
c'est on l'avait envisagé d'ailleurs là
c'est une des possibilités une
déclaration de guerre formelle
ça n'est pas du tout intervenu dans son
discours
dit à quelques jours son discours dit il
y a quelques jours c'était une sorte de
de grandes
litanie nationalistes sur justifications
des Occidentaux et
l'histoire encore une fois de de la
Grande Russie du monde russe etc de
manière concrète il y a pas eu grand
chose à part la suspension de la Russie
du traité de
nucléaire on reparlera plus tard mais il
y a pas eu du Grand d'annonce ni de
mobilisation ni de déclaration de guerre
ni etc et donc du coup ça va plutôt dans
l'idée que on peut s'attendre à ce que
les russes continuent cette stratégie de
grignotage de guerre d'usure mais ne
vont pas se lancer dans une série de
manœuvres les seuls on va prendre des
exemples ils ont lancé des manœuvres
plus au sud dans une ville qui s'appelle
vous blédard
au sud du don-basse
l'ouest de denietzk de la ville de
danielsk ça s'est soldé par un échec
pour les pour les Russes encore une le
choix ils ont une capacité de manœuvre
notamment avec leurs chars qui est
extrêmement faible de nouveau on a vu
des chats avancés en colonne ce qui peut
paraître très étonnant alors est-ce que
c'était pour éviter les champs de mignes
il y a moins de chance si mais le
résultat c'est qu'on a vu des dizaines
de chars se faire détruire à vous
blédard et
dans la région de plus au nord
l'intersection exacte entre le rouge et
le jaune il y a une grande forêt qui
s'appelle autour de criminat et donc les
Russes poussent à criminat pour aller
pour rejoindre la rivière et plus tard
la rivière au skills arrive et donc dans
cette grande forêt il y a quelques il y
a deux jours peut-être les Russes ont
tenté une une percée et on ne le
résultat c'est qu'on a vu 14 chats
Russes
se faire détruire littéralement par les
Ukrainiens dont un très moderne chart et
90 m
donc voilà les Russes n'ont pas du tout
retrouvé aujourd'hui leur capacités de
manœuvre même si il est probable ça
c'est ce que la plupart des analystes
disent que là les Russes n'ont pas jeté
sur le front tous les derniers
garde des forces en réserves de même les
Ukrainiens
c'est extrêmement rude pour eux autour
de backmouth
pour un reparler des filles tout à
l'heure c'est compliqué mais enfin c'est
extrêmement
coûteux en homme et en matériel malgré
tout il semblerait qu'ils aient des
batailles des brigades de réserves
qu'ils ont gardé en stock à l'arrière du
front et qu'ils n'ont pour l'instant pas
mobilisés donc du coup la question c'est
est-ce que les Russes et les Ukrainiens
chacun de leur côté conservent
suffisamment d'hommes pour lancer le
jour venu des contrôles de nouvelles
offensives et là c'est vraiment la
question du printemps c'est ça parce que
qui se pose on parle beaucoup de la
Russie des contrats
ukrainiennes au printemps alors il peut
il peut y en avoir moi
il y a plein d'analyses qui font du
travail en Open en source zine c'est à
dire source ouverte
à partir de de la presse des réseaux
sociaux etc et c'est assez fascinant et
donc il y a un chercheur qui a réussi
reconstituer à peu près l'an de
batailles
Ukrainiens aujourd'hui c'est une
question que vous me posiez souvent dans
les précédents live et je vous répondais
l'armée ukrainienne c'est entre 400 à
peu près 400 000 hommes et on était
probablement pas très loin de ça puisque
lors de bataille musulmans c'est
sensible brigade dont 17 en formation ce
qui représente un total de 267
000 à 424000 hommes que là que la la
l'Ukraine peut véritablement
utilisé au combat pas forcément
aujourd'hui on va dire dans les dans les
semaines et les mois à venir mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que sur ces
sensibles brigades actuellement il n'y a
que quatre brigades blindées qui a une
brigades de chars qui sont là pour
typiquement dans une offensive percer
les lignes adverses nions donc 4 ce qui
n'est vraiment pas considérable et il y
en a deux nouvelles en formation et on
sait que l'ayez les chats occidentaux
qui vont arriver bon pour l'instant
c'est assez flou sur quand ils vont
arriver quel chat puisque au début on va
y avoir
principe il y a les 14 challengers
britannique mais ça c'est trop petit
pour pour compter il y avait les
Abrahams américains mais en fait on a
réalisé que les Abrahams américains
n'arriveront pas avant un an et s'ils
arrivent un jour et donc en fait le cœur
de cette aide occidentale c'est les
chars de fabrication allemandes léopard
2 qui sont des chars pour le coup très
moderne de différents pays puisqu'en
Europe il y en a à peu près il y en a
et donc c'est les ordres de grandeur
sont sont crédit c'est-à-dire que si les
pays européens se départissent de 10% de
leur chat on est à 170 chars et on
regardait les promesses ont
effectivement on est arrivé à quelques
200 chars
sauf que on se rend compte désormais que
c'est les haut-par2 en fait ils vont pas
arriver avant probablement plusieurs
mois et que dans un premier temps les
chars qui vont arriver probablement
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on déclarait les
Allemands les chars qui vont arriver
dans un premier temps dans la fin du
mois de mars début avril au mieux ce
sont des chars léopards 1 ils ont
beaucoup plus anciens faut dire les
charlés aux pains 1 c'est des chars qui
ont été construits pour combattre les
vieux chats T62 soviétiques des années
60 donc c'est vraiment du
vieux matériel
et donc voilà c'est la capacité de de
l'armée ukrainienne à reconstituer une
force de char suffisante pour mener des
offensives c'est encore une inconnue
surtout que là on a l'impression
que tout d'un coup les occidentaux se
sont mis à livrer des chats oui alors on
livre pas des chars comme ça en Ukraine
non mais surtout des chars on en livre
depuis le début oui et dans des ordres
de grandeur considérable mais simplement
on livrait des anciens chats de
fabrication soviétiques donc des chats
notamment des chars polonais des charts
tchèques des chats seven mais si vous
voulez pour là encore une fois parlons
dans du vendeurs depuis le début de la
guerre les pays occidentaux ont livré à
l'Ukraine environ 300 chars T72 et
autres donc si vous voulez c'est
considérable et de et donc si vous
voulez c'est pas
son char léopard 1 dans un mois qui vont
radicalement changé la donne sur le
terrain donc d'où la question principale
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce qu'on rentre
durablement dans une guerre d'usure et
là combien de temps chacun des deux
belligé en peut tenir ou est-ce que on
va au printemps à l'été vers un
renouveau de la guerre de mano et ça
franchement les
occidentales justement qui a qui a
évolué tout au long de cette de cette
guerre mais on sent aujourd'hui que les
Occidentaux sont complètement pro pour
donner des armes à l'Ukraine ah bah
c'est monté en puissance c'est-à-dire
que si on regarde au départ c'était du
matériel plutôt léger si je caricature
au début c'était des casques et des
gilles par balles et on est arrivé au
chat et là on se demande si on va pas
leur livrer des c'est moins c'est moins
évident que ça au début il y avait ces
missiles portatifs qu'on porte à les à
l'épaule à la frontière
anti-chat en réalité rapidement il y a
eu des équipements extrêmement lourds
vous commencez par de la retirer
que ça soit les canons Césars français
les obusier américain aiment 777
des obusiers allemands enfin bref il y
en a eu plein et notamment le point
d'angle de ça ça a été les
lance-roquettes multiples américains
donc qui ont une portée de 80 km et
surtout une précision de l'ordre du
maître et qui a eu un impact sur la
ligne de front parce que les Russes ont
dû repousser leur centre logistique plus
loin la ligne de France qui du coup
ralentit les ralentis encore leur
capitaine manoeuvre donc de l'armement
lourd il y en a eu dès le début
simplement il y a des moments où il y a
des moments on parle de l'artillerie
puis il y a des moments par des chats
ensuite on a parlé des avions là il
semblerait que la
parenthèse avion ce sont un peu refermé
parce qu'on se rend compte que de toute
façon compliqué ça sera compliqué ça va
prendre du temps de former les pilotes
et puis pour quel impact réel sur les
lignes de fond parce qu'en fait les
c'est pas parce que les l'aviation russe
a du mal aller en Ukraine que l'aviation
ukrainienne va réussir à aller sur le
terrain
du côté russe parce qu'il y a quand même
des défenses aériennes russes enfin bref
donc si vous voulez il y a il faut se
méfier de ce travers un peu médiatique
qui est de se focaliser à un moment sur
un type d'armement les Ukrainiens dont
ils ont besoin surtout c'est d'une
système d'armes diverses cohérent en
nombre en masse et principalement ils
ont besoin de blindés pour de la
manœuvre et surtout et avant tout de la
retirer c'est la mère des batailles et
là il y a c'est vraiment on est dans la
guerre d'attrition et le stoltonberg le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN parlait il
y a quelques jours
aujourd'hui
la guerre en Ukraine
use davantage de d'obus
[Musique]
officiellement c'est une région de la
Moldavie
alors la Moldavie c'est le pays oui
de l'Ukraine et alors la transition
c'est vraiment une bande de terre
très très fine tout le long de la
frontière avec l'Ukraine c'est une
région qui est historiquement pour russe
il y a deux régions pour eux sans
Moldavie il y a elle le long de la
frontière ukrainienne et il y a une
région qui s'appelle gagawsi qui est
plus au sud et donc en fait cette région
en 1991 à la chute de Lurs elle a deux
facto pris son indépendance donc les
deux facto autonomes même si le point de
droit elle fait partie de la Moldavie et
depuis
91 il y a 1500 soldats russes
qui se stationne en transmettrie un peu
pour
consacrer cet état de fait
ça c'est le contexte historique et la
Moldavie
historiquement a été assez proche des
Russes en tout cas a toujours essayé de
de trouver un équilibre notamment parce
qu'ils ont besoin d'un gaz pas cher et
dès que il y a un gouvernement un peu
anti-rhus hop la Russie augmente le prix
du gaz et donc justement de depuis deux
ans maintenant trois ans je veux pas
dire de bêtises il y a un gouvernement
pro européen en Maldives et la Moldavie
se rapproche pas à pas de l'OTAN de
l'Union européenne etc d'où
mécontentement
assez prononcé de Moscou
alors maintenant
quelle est la situation
ce qui est étonnant c'est que
comme l'offensive russe vers l'Ouest
dont on parlait tout à l'heure à échouer
vénère peut-il se retrouve un peu coincé
parce qu'il n'y a aucun moyen
d'intervenir militairement
en transcrit parce que l'espace aérien
ukrainien si alors du coup il y a pardon
du coup il y a eu un changement de
féministe on Moldavie mais pour des
raisons il y a un chercheur Florent
Parentis comme parler il y a plein de
régions économiques de d'inflation etc
qui explique largement la chute de ce
gouvernement mais simplement il y a eu
tout un tas de déclaration des
Ukrainiens des moldavres etc sur
l'hypothèse d'un coup d'État russe pour
établir des prorus en Moldavie et il y a
encore un grand parti prorus en Moldavie
et donc même on parlait d'une opération
aéroportée pour prendre le contrôle de
l'aéroport de chizineau établiant
donc ça c'est ce que c'est la crainte
des moldaves et la crainte des des
Ukrainiens les Russes eux agitent une
une autre menace de vues de leur côté
c'est que les Ukrainiens s'apprêteraient
à franchir la frontière
à envahir la transmistrie où il y a à
peu près 1500 soldats russes donc les
Ukrainiens n'auraient pas de mal à
paraître territoire pour une raison
c'est que la transistorie depuis 1991 et
une grande plaque tournante du trafic
d'armes et il y a des dépôts de
munitions qui datent de l'Union
soviétique
en très grande masse et donc les
Ukrainiens ayant
urgemment besoin de munitions et
notamment de munitions de type
soviétique parce que la majorité des
pièces d'artillerie et des équipements
militaires de manière générale utilisée
par les Ukrainiens sont d'origine
soviétique et donc les Ukrainiens
voudraient
envahir comme ça la Transnistrie qui
officiellement un territoire moldave
alors il y a ces deux éléments de
langage qui se font face
déstabilisation russe de la Moldavie
pour pour
déstabiliser les régions et faire
s'étendre le conflit etc etc et
tentative ukrainienne de s'emparer de
l'intensité
pour l'instant il y a aucun élément
concret qui vient à valider cela donc
faut attendre dans les prochains jours
il y a la guerre il y a la guerre des
mots il y a aussi une escalade dans la
guerre des mots
et donc il faut regarder ça avec
beaucoup de distance avec beaucoup de
prudence alors on parlait justement de
cette guerre des mots de cette guerre
voilà juste un point militairement ça
serait complètement fou
que les Russes essayent quelque chose en
transmetterie en transistorique je ne
vois pas il y aurait une possibilité
parce que vous voyez le fait la Moldavie
n'a pas d'accès à la mer
du crâne
c'est le bout de Jack
et donc il faudrait que les Russes
tentent une mission amphibie avec des
avec des bateaux et même qu'il y a pas
de porc avec des avions pour tenir une
tête de pont et filer en transmisserie
tout ça tout ça sans tout ça sans en
évitant tout problème avec la Roumanie
qui est juste à côté c'est franchement
ça serait du genre je sais que les
Russes nous ont habitués depuis un an à
des manœuvres bizarres mais là ça serait
complètement fou quand tu as une
déstabilisation de la Moldavie pour
mettre un gouvernement pour eux
et non par rapport à un il y a un nom
non
c'est très clair le le jour où il y aura
un risque nucléaire
qui sera pour le coup assez prégnant
c'est le jour où les russes seront
réellement en route
et je veux dire en déroute à des
endroits qui pour eux
sont vraiment
pas ça serait vraiment un camoufler
insupportable donc la Crimée
peut-être le
don boeuf pareil peut-être le don-basse
la partie du don-basse contre les par
2014 c'est vraiment dans l'hypothèse
d'une défaite militaire russe que cette
question se posera sinon la formule de
Bruno tertrée qui est à mon avis le bon
mot c'est un conflit conventionnel qui
se déroule dans une ambiance nucléaire
c'est-à-dire que
le nucléaire a un impact sur le conflit
au sens où les Ukrainiens les
Occidentaux comme les Russes savent que
ils savent pas exactement sur les lignes
rouges mais il y a un certain nombre de
choses
qui n'ont pas envie de faire parce que
sinon on rentrerait dans un conflit
nucléaire non pas au sens où il y aurait
forcément une attaque nucléaire mais
on commencerait à escalader les les
marches de la justement la grammaire du
cloud typiquement
je pense que des troupes
occidentales de l'OTAN formellement en
Ukraine qui viendrait se battre contre
des troupes russes
le nucléaire explique en grande partie
pourquoi ça n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
c'est bon on rentrerait dans un dans une
guerre d'une autre dimension
quand même une chose
là encore les
il y a eu parfois des des peurs un peu
un peu exacerbé sur le nucléaire on a
beaucoup parlé un moment de du missile
russe sarmat comme si c'est mais le
missila il n'a pas de rapport avec les
guerres Ukraine c'est un missile
intercontinental de nouvelles
générations ça fait 10 ans enfin ça fait
15 ans dont on connaît ce projet ça fait
des années qu'on savait que dans les
années à venir il y aurait probablement
un test de Sarmates qui visiblement
d'ailleurs à échoué
ça n'a rien de nouveau
quant à la homo utilisé
Vladimir Poutine pour l'instant
a toujours respecté
la doctrine militaire russe mais de même
que les occidentaux il y a pas eu pour
l'instant de dérapage
verbales sur la question nucléaire il y
a des gens autour de Poutine donc VDF
elle est un peu plus loin quoi que
mettre je crois pas que formellement il
est quitté le champ de la doctrine
mitterieuse et après il y a des excités
à la télévision russe mais le l'État
russe pour l'instant a toujours répété
les quatre
conditions dans lesquelles la Russie
pourrait engager l'arme nucléaire et
simplement la difficulté c'est qu'on
sait que la Russie pourrait utiliser
l'arme nucléaire
pas forcément face à du nucléaire c'est
considère que l'existence de l'État
et mise en jeu et là il y a évidemment
un flou sur ce que les Russes veulent
dire par là effectivement alors on parle
aussi des alliés de de la lumière
Poutine il y a le rôle de la Chine avec
une déclaration peut-être à venir de
Xyl déclaration à venir d'oxygène pink
si j'ai une pink va se rendre
à Moscou on sait que il a présenté une
forme de plan de paix en 12 points
franchement c'est pas du tout précis
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est à
la fois ça appelle à une chambre de
désescalade ça c'est sur le la partie
militaire
à la paix et puis par ailleurs il y a
toute une dimension de ce plan qui qui
vise à là les Occidentaux qui critiquent
les sanctions
uneilatérale c'est les sanctions qui
sont pas prises dans le cadre du Conseil
de sécurité
et donc évidemment ce plan de paix en
l'état et impensable
c'est que les Ukrainiens ne
l'accepteront pas les Occidentaux
l'accepteront pas pourquoi parce que
pour l'instant
on n'a pas atteint un point culminant
enfin en tout cas les deux belligérants
n'ont pas la conviction d'avoir un teint
point culminant sur le sur le théâtre
des armes qui obligerait à négocier et
donc on en est on en est pas là alors la
question maintenant c'est quelle va être
l'attitude de la Chine à l'endroit de la
Russie on sait que s'il y a un
partenariat stratégique quand on entre
les deux pays maintenant on a plus aucun
doute
en revanche
on apparence en tout cas la Chine a
toujours observé à l'endroit de la
guerre en Ukraine une forme de
neutralité en tout cas elle s'est jamais
encouragé ou soutenu directement la
Russie on sait qu'elle le fait
indirectement parce que c'est parce
qu'elle Achille que la Russie arrive à
contourner les sanctions en ayant un
accès à des à des technologies la
question de des hydrocarbures etc on
peut même imaginer que la que la Chine
son idée déjà des peut-être des pièces
détachées etc pour pour et pour soutenir
le le
l'effort de guerre russes et pour
l'instant on n'est jamais au-delà là les
Occidentaux s'inquiètent formellement
ils l'ont dit
du fait que la Chine pourrait livrer des
armes
à la Russie et là
faudrait voir faudra voir si c'est le
cas déjà ensuite faudrait voir dans quel
proportion
donc il est trop tôt pour pour
envisager d'éventuelles conséquences
mais en revanche je voudrais imaginer
l'impact si la Chine s'impliquait
davantage que ça soit par le biais
diplomatique ou par le biais militaire
il faut imaginer l'impact
politique que c'est heureux une guerre
sur le vieux continent au cœur de
l'Occident et avec la grande puisse
superpuissance émergentes le seul pire
compétiteur de la des États-Unis
qui vient et qui Singère sens propre du
terme comme les états de l'Occident ça
serait
extrêmement significatif du monde dans
lequel on vit c'était un monde Isabelle
lacet on parlait dans son papier d'hier
un monde où deux facto on observe une
désoxydantalisation du monde qu'on le
veuille ou non le ce qu'on appelle le
sud global là aujourd'hui un poids
politique économique etc qui fait que le
monde n'est plus dicté par par les
Occidentaux mais de là ce que la Chine
Vienne peser de tout son poids que ça
soit diplomatique économique militaire
dans une guerre qui a lieu en plein cœur
du continent européen là ça serait
encore une autre étape de franchi
effectivement alors je vais vous montrer
cet article
Ukraine la guerre qui a bouleversé
l'ordre mondial un article de d'Isabelle
Lasserre
retrouver bien évidemment sur le site du
Figaro très intéressant un grand récit
très intéressant géopolitique qui vous
parle de ce qui se passe merci beaucoup
Alexis on va terminer ce live merci à
vous d'avoir été une nouvelle fois très
nombreux à nous suivre merci forcément
aussi au service infographies qui nous a
fait cette magnifique carte animée
retrouvée bravo à eux une nouvelle fois
et merci une nouvelle fois à vous d'être
du Figaro d'avoir été nombreux à nous
suivre d'avoir on vous fera des live et
bien évidemment rester avec nous pour
suivre toute la formation sur ce conflit
un journal spécial d'ailleurs que vous
vous retrouvez aujourd'hui le Figaro
avec une sur spéciale autour de la
guerre en Ukraine merci une nouvelle
fois je vais vous dire à bientôt pour de
nouvelles live sur figarolive